four episodes in and wandavision keeps
revealing new and more interesting
layers to the strange new reality
to find out what's hidden in this
intriguing tv show keep watching for
easter eggs you missed in wandavision
we interrupt this program opens with the
first extended on-screen depiction of
the blip the resurrection of all the
people killed by thanos snap in avengers
infinity war
spider-man far from home lets us know
how the event comes to be known as the
blip and some of the consequences of it
but this is the first time we get a good
long look at the chaos immediately
following the event
specifically we see monica rambo
returning from the dead in a hospital
room where her mother was a patient
during the events of infinity war
as rambo's body reforms we hear dialogue
from 2019's captain marvel
your mom's lucky when they were handing
out kids
they gave her the toughest one
lieutenant trouble
he remembered it's a fitting way to
start the episode considering one of the
biggest mysteries the story presents is
how the synthesized vision has returned
from the dead
considering all the hints that have been
dropped in the previous three episodes
it's no surprise to learn that monica
rambo works for sword
her scenes with director hayward pretty
strongly imply that she was the front
runner for his job before thanos's snap
made that impossible
but while she may not have the top
position monica isn't without rank and
sword
after monica's security badge doesn't
work at headquarters director hayward
shows up and introduces her to the
security guard as captain monica rambo
the rank isn't an accident when she
shows up in marvel comics monica is a
different kind of captain
after obtaining the ability to transform
into any form of energy monika becomes
known as captain marvel
years before carol danvers takes up the
title
in the opening scene of the episode we
learn that maria rambo is dead
from a conversation between monica and
dr hyland it's revealed that at some
point between the events of captain
marvel and those of infinity war maria
was diagnosed with cancer
when thanos made his fateful snap maria
had just undergone a procedure to treat
her cancer and it was deemed a success
because thanos's snap wiped monica from
existence she awakes not knowing that
her mother's cancer soon returned and
she died three years before the blip
but when monica returns to sword it's
clear her mother isn't forgotten
as director hayward leads monica into
the headquarters they pass by a number
of portraits
including one of maria rambo with her
callsign photon
maria wasn't just a high-ranking member
of sword either
hayward says she built this place from
the ground up which makes sense
after all sword in the comics deals with
extraterrestrial threats
and as far as we know maria is one of
the first few mcu earthlings to
knowingly have contact with any
extraterrestrials
we first meet fbi agent wu in 2019's
ant-man and the wasp when wu was in
charge of babysitting scott lang while
lang's under house arrest were violating
the sokovia accords in captain america's
civil war
in one division he's the fbi agent
waiting for monica rambo to help him
with his missing persons case
and their introduction to one another
includes an easter egg from his very
first mcu scene
in ant-man and the wasp scott used his
sleight of hand to make a playing card
appear out of thin air
later wu has an important question for
scott how'd you do it scott
do what the car trick
seriously it turns out woo's a huge fan
of sleight of hand
and wanda vision reveals that he's been
honing his skills since babysitting
scott
as he's approaching monica for the first
time he uses the same trick to produce
his business card
during the montage that shows us the
progress of the joint task force
investigation we get a couple of shots
of agent wu taking notes on a dry erase
board
under the heading what is behind this wu
is written extraterrestrials
scrolls we first meet the shape-shifting
scrolls in captain marvel
and what we know about them so far makes
wu's notion very interesting
while scrolls are traditionally villains
in the comics captain marvel shows that
they're just trying to survive being
annihilated by the cree in the mcu
captain marvel and her allies help the
aliens and in the mid-credits scene of
spider-man far from home they appear to
be working with nick fury
so why would agent wu or anyone else
suspect them of something nefarious
it could be that relations between earth
and the scrolls have changed
another possibility is that while
captain marvel seemed to imply its
scrolls were some of the last the cree
hadn't wiped out
maybe there are more of the
shapeshifters out there who aren't as
friendly as the ones working with nick
fury
the conclusion of we interrupt this
program implies that wanda is behind all
the weirdness going on in wandavision at
least that's monica's theory
when wanda uses her power to hurl monica
beyond the boundaries of westview and
she lands among the joint task force
monika has one conclusion
it's all wonder
the episode ends with wanda and vision
sitting down with their newborn twins to
watch some tv
as the jimi hendrix experiences 1968
voodoo child slight return plays
the song is a perfect cap to we
interrupt this program for a couple of
reasons
while the word voodoo can refer to any
number of things an american pop culture
is often associated with witchcraft
making the song just one of a growing
list of things referencing witchcraft in
the series
more importantly there are the opening
lyrics hendrix sings
well i stand up next to a mountain and i
chop it down with the edge of my hand
then later in the verse we hear will i
pick up all pieces and make an island
might even raise a little sand
if monica is right and wanda is behind
everything going on in west view then
the imagery of someone chopping down
mountains and using the debris to build
an island is pretty fitting for the
series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one